do non-politicians make the best
politicians
a new online poll my favorite kind
reveals that most americans want to see
people like matthew mcconaughey and
dwayne johnson run for office
the poll finds that 58 percent of
respondents said they'd support
mcconaughey
running for texas governor and dwayne
johnson running for president
as you know johnson goes by the name the
rock he actually stole my high school
nickname
dwayne johnson but they're both highly
popular thoughtful individuals who emit
charisma like flatulence from a cattle
farm
so why shouldn't they run it's not like
politicians are doing a good job of
being politicians
when makani he makes a movie it's either
a hit or it's not and when the rock
jumped off a
top rope he made sure he landed on that
elbow
did i say that right it shows you i know
nothing about wrestling
anyway it kind of reminds me of abe
lincoln maybe the best politician is
someone who hasn't been corrupted by the
system
someone who has had a private sector job
even if it's pretend
the animal who isn't in it for the
prestige or the interns
i'd rather they show up rich and
powerful than leave that way
we saw this with trump he wasn't
impressed by the perks or the power he
already had those
even air force one was a step down
unlike joe biden
where air force one was a step up and a
step down
then a step up and then step down that's
good
meanwhile that's it caitlyn jenner is
said to be exploring a run
for california governor with gavin
newsom facing a recall a challenge from
jenner a republican could prove as
deadly as
bumming a ride from tiger woods
jenner has better hair and could still
beat gavin in the 440 wearing a pair of
louis batons
remember the last time california
recalled the governor the winner was
arnold
a republican celebrity and if jenner
wins talk about a first
they'll probably put her on a wheaties
box
joey i tried to get you to run for
office do you remember that no
no i forgot all about that i don't you
don't need me in office number one i'd
have to survive the advent of the
internet
i mean yeah i was a marine for eight
years i i love the fact that you'd
rather disarm minds that blew your legs
off than run for office cause
oh you're scared of running for office
bombs are honest
i know what they're in it for i know
what they want out of it and they're
they're very honestly trying to deceive
me
yes politicians there's nothing there
what makes celebrities
such good you know like options for
politicians is that
we we know they can lie to our face and
make us believe it
and you know with politicians they're
trying to pretend they're not
that's yeah that's what that was the
trump appeal right it's not that what he
said offended you is that he was willing
to say it
yes it also loftus it was like trump
would always like almost
point to the politician and go what is
with this guy i mean that was this whole
thing
from when he started he just kept going
it's like forget about me
i'm not perfect i'm you know i'm an
arrogant obnoxious tv host
yeah but those guys and everybody was
like finally somebody saying those guys
and he's running against him
yeah and that's it's it's happening now
it's like deja vu all over again
i've never heard that phrase like right
now you come up with that yourself
absolutely it's deja vu all over it
hey did you come up with that yourself i
did
oh cat guys that left it there like a
bible at an
orgy
[Laughter]
i love i love the idea of celebrities
running uh for public office this is
great because they think they know what
they're doing
yeah they're so wrapped up in their own
bs and they're surrounded by people
telling them they're wonderful
and they they think they know that
hollywood is horrible and it doesn't get
worse
it does politics is so much worse they
chew these people up and they spit them
out
they ruined arnold yeah that's true
that's true he was never the same he
wasn't
now he's like making youtube videos
talking to a pony i don't like trump
anymore
i mean it's it's amazing after he was
governor he just couldn't act anymore
it was over they broke him they crushed
him up into tiny bits
the joke was that he could never act
michael but that was okay
he wanted to keep the impression he
played a fantastic robot
and is a guy who's half robot i know
that he played a
fantastic robot jingle all the way was
the best that wasn't good
it's not a tumor in the goddamn cop come
on where are we going with this cat who
would you like to see run for office
missy elliott
oh there you go no i'm serious like
thank you i was a wick on the buzzer no
i
look like i think about it like
in terms of my principles i think it's
dangerous this whole cult of personality
and following that but i also know that
if missy elliot were to run for office i
would quit my job
and follow her and try to get and then
maybe come on the air to like only
defend everything she did or said
which goes back to why that's wrong and
you got to be careful
i just could never imagine saying
anything bad about missy elliott i want
to see her campaign commercial
exactly all right well maybe one day you
know sunny
uh the person who introduced you to me
andrew breitbart had a
famous saying politics downstream from
culture
right and that's the problem with the
republican party
there's not a lot of culture there no
they have
no culture if they just you know anytime
it comes anywhere near him they make
sure they send out the pulse beam to
send it far away running fast
but the thing about why politicians i
mean why
non-politicians are running for
political spots is because politicians
suck so bad yeah
so if you have people that don't know
policy that don't know context that
don't know history that don't
understand anything about the current
political standing they just want to
jump in and regurgitate talking points
that is what america is tired of yeah
and i think if you look at a lot of
what's going on with like the black
voting rights and stuff
democrats are saying oh that their
voters are being suppressed
no we just don't believe you anymore
yeah you can't get
us to want to register anymore you can't
get us to want to vote anymore
you can't make us buy your lies anymore
so you want to get a cultural icon that
is better at
selling them than you are but they're
going to hire the same consultant yeah
right they're going to hire the same pr
firms and they're going to push the same
bs that the politicians are pushing
and that's what i learned from trump
yeah i think that if you want to be the
president then you're too crazy to be
the president
i think you have to want to be the
president but you have to want to learn
something yeah like people are so just
at peace with being idiots that is the
part to me
that i can't get past how happy people
are being dumped so we should just hear
you after our president then you know
like you draft people into war we're
gonna dr
you're a sane individual with good ideas
i know you don't want to but we're gonna
make you be president does anybody
remember the phone book party
no yeah there was an experience where
most americans polled like thank you had
a dream
back it was like deja vu all over again
i've never been there
most americans back when you had a phone
book would vote for not a republican or
democrat but people randomly chosen from
the phone book
i love that